Hello everyone, I
'm Koizumi, the general producer of Nintendo Switch.
Thanks to you, Nintendo Mizuchi has been played by many customers all over the world
.
You can take it off and play with someone,
and then dog out the switch and take it out to various places to
play in a free style
.
It
's a Nintendo switch light for mobile use that was included. The
Nintendo installation light seems to be portable, so it
's ideal for playing with a small and light
drop.
Nintendo Mizuchi Light comes in 3 colors
Yellow
Greater Koise,
then here
[Music]
3 types
Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah wh p Lord Yeah Yeah Yeah [Music] me Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah  Yeah yeah
th
Good adele
[Music]
[Music
] Did
Nintendo Mizuchi join the Nintendo Mizuchi family and it seems that you can take it to various places and
play it?
Yes, yeah
Nintendo Mizuchi Ride has different characteristics from Nintendo
Mizuchi Let's introduce
[Music]
mar
Introduction Nintendo Underwater Light is for mobile use, so it can't be connected to TV
[Music] Make it
easier to take out  In order to make the controller larger than the main body, the
direction button has been changed to a cross button.
The controller of Nintendo Switch Light is not Joy now,
so it does motion. There
is no camera or hd vibration.
Soft etc.
For example,
you need bed joy money to play 12 switches.
Nintendo Mizuchi Light can be played in mobile mode. You
can play all Nintendo Switch games.
Stylan and Smash Blur Guard Special and Super Mario
pizza  Legend of breath of the bad
Mario Cart 8 Deluxe and many more games
There is a sign on the back of the game software package that indicates that it is compatible with mobile
mode. As you can see, the
Nintendo Underwater Light may differ from Nintendo Water Time,
so be
sure to check here when purchasing.
A new companion to Nintendo Switch
Nintendo Mizuchi Light
will be easier to take out and will be available for portability
. You will have more fun to choose from in the world of Nintendo Switch play according to your favorite play style.
It's
still a while before it goes on sale, but please enjoy
it. Thank you for watching until the end.
[Music]
[Applause]